bonjour bonjour à tous et merci
de vous être connecté pour cette
audition donc mes chers collègues
présentes bonjour installez-vous alors
avant d'ouvrir l'audition de ce matin à
l'attention de nos collègues je vous
signale le déplacement que nous
organisons lundi prochain anni
Ille-et-Vilaine auquel vous êtes invité
à participer si vous ne l'avez pas déjà
signalé et je vous propose à présent
d'ouvrir cette table ronde où nous avons
le plaisir d'accueillir un
visioconférence pour l'association des
mers ruraux de France Monsieur Carteret
mais que nous attendons visiblement qui
n'est pas encore connecté maire de
l'Avent en cours dans le département de
Haute-Saône qui est vice-président de
l'association ainsi que Monsieur Michel
gros maire de La Roquebrussanne dans le
Var et membre de son bureau
avec nous ici présents pour
l'association des petites villes de
France Monsieur Daniel cornalba qui est
membre de son bureau et maire de
l'Étang-la-Ville dans les Yvelines que
nous libérerons rapidement donc on va
vous donner la priorité pour pour
intervenir ce matin et enfin également
en visioconférence pour l'association
ville de France Monsieur Frédéric
Chereau maire de Douai et monsieur Éric
Straumann maire de Colmar
membre du conseil d'administration de
l'association alors nous avions aussi
convié à cette table ronde l'association
en France urbaine qui n'a
malheureusement pas pu être présente ce
matin mais qui enverra à la mission
d'information une contribution écrite et
que les rendre sa position sur les
sujets qui nous intéressent messieurs le
sujet examiné par notre mission
d'informations vous le connaissez c'est
l'avenir de la commune et du maire votre
témoignage nous est donc
particulièrement précieux à la fois pour
cerner les difficultés auxquelles sont
confrontées les catégories de communes
et de mer que vous représentez mais
aussi pour identifier les solutions qui
se dessinent pour garantir aux communes
un avenir conforme à ce qu'attendre les
élus et nos concitoyens et je passe donc
sans plus attendre la parole à notre
rapporteur pour entamer nos échanges de
ce matin
merci
messieurs pour avoir répondu à cette
invitation et puis pour répondre aux
différentes interrogations que nous nous
posons dans le cadre de cette mission
d'information je ne vais pas allonger le
propos je vais tout de suite vous donner
la parole et nous aurons ensuite un
échange nous pourrons rebondir et vous
interroger pardon sur différents aspects
qui constituent un petit peu les
différentes attentes et questionnements
de notre de notre mission voilà donc je
crois qu'on nous allons commencer par
Monsieur cornalbin à qui je cède la
parole sans plus attendre
bonjour madame la Présidente messieurs
les sénateurs merci vraiment de cet
exercice à mon avis important pour
souligner à la fois les forces et les
faiblesses du bloc communal dans son
ensemble et singulièrement celui des
mers vous avez notamment fixé poser
cette question un peu en intitulé
l'avenir des mers et des communes à
l'horizon 2030
ce sur quoi j'aimerais en tout cas en
propos liminaire insisté et c'est ce qui
ressort à la fois des études que nous
menons en tant qu'association des
petites villes de France donc pour
rappel ce sont évidemment les villes de
2500 à 25000 habitants ce qui représente
à peu près un gros tiers de la
population française et évidemment dans
un contexte d'évolution très forte suite
à la crise sanitaire notamment on voit
un essor de cette échelon là de commune
en tout cas de petites villes avec une
recherche à la fois d'une relative
qualifie une grande qualité de vie mais
en même temps aussi cette relative
centralité que peuvent avoir les petites
villes qui sont les nôtres évidemment en
lien avec les
une rurale et on les entendra tout à
l'heure dans un instant moi ce sur quoi
nous souhaitions évidemment insister par
d'autres associations des petites villes
de France c'est la confiance qui ressort
année après année dans les études qui
sont faites des études d'opinion mais
également celle que nous menons en tant
qu'association c'est-à-dire que le maire
et la commune reste finalement l'instant
qui garde encore je dis encore une
confiance des citoyens donc pour moi ça
c'est un joyeux dans une période pour le
moins marqué par la défiance à l'égard
des institutions
et un sentiment aussi de crise permanent
et qu'on parle le sentiment de crise
permanence évidemment celle des gilets
jaunes il faudrait pas oublier la
question de la crise sanitaire la
question évidemment de l'inflation qui
nous marque et qui forcément nous
interpellent dans les moyens qui sont
donnés aux communes pour leur donner la
capacité d'agir
vous nous avez donné toute une
multiplicité de questions donc je sais
pas comment vous souhaitez procéder
est-ce que vous dès qu'on les aborde une
à une parce que je préférais ne pas être
trop long mais vraiment en propos
liminaire c'est ce sentiment là de
confiance qui existe encore et en même
temps la la force la résilience la
capacité d'adaptation qu'on suprouver à
mon sens les maires des communes de
France pendant toutes ces crises et ça
c'est ce qui est quand même en ressort
que bien souvent quand y compris l'État
a pu être je vais pas dire frapper des
froids mais en tout cas dans une
capacité une difficulté à répondre à une
certaine urgence je pense à la crise
sanitaire il a fallu être concrètement
sur le terrain et je pense que pour moi
les maires ont été c'était chaud de la
proximité de l'écoute et donc c'est
évidemment un point si on veut maintenir
une un sentiment de d'adhésion aux
institutions je pense qu'il faut
s'appuyer évidemment sur sur ce ressort
là qui fait la force des mères
[Musique]
je disais est-ce que vous souhaitez
qu'on
passait question en revue qu'on
excuse-moi vous pouvez enfin en fonction
de ce que vous jugez comme prioritaire
par rapport à l'ensemble des questions
qui sont très assez vastes
essayer de balayer un champ qui est qui
est relativement étendu et peut-être
aussi et surtout mais là je m'adresse à
chacun de nous donner un peu la lecture
qui est la vôtre et surtout quel serait
selon vous les les pistes pour redonner
le souffle nécessaire et attendu aux
communes et surtout à leurs
du coup je me permets de rebondir
immédiatement je pense que les collègues
pourront évidemment aussi se joindre à
moi là-dessus la question était
effectivement quel est l'avenir des
maires et des communes à l'horizon 2030
une réponse que j'ai envie de donner
c'est qu'évidemment pour moi les maires
le rôle qu'ils ont eu qu'ils ont doit
aussi être celui qu'ils auront dans
quelques années ça paraît peut-être une
évidence à vous sénateurs mais à mon
sens évidemment on préconisera ici pas
la suppression des communes des deux au
contraire je pense qu'elles ont prouvé
toutes leurs forces et donc là aussi
c'est une instance à préserver notamment
un certain nombre de questions que vous
posiez était le lien avec
l'intercommunalité
moi simplement ce sur quoi je veux
insister c'est qu'il y a eu énormément
de changements institutionnels en termes
d'intercaux c'est un avis aussi
personnel que j'exprime mais je pense
pas que changer constamment les échelons
et en tout cas consommer les périmètres
des intercos les rendra plus efficaces
en tout cas à titre personnel néanmoins
la vision que nous avons c'est que les
interco doivent être des
démultiplicateurs de l'action locale
c'est-à-dire pour moi être vraiment dans
une logique de compétences d'appui pour
renforcer les politiques qui sont menées
évidemment les intercos ont un sens et
soulignons-le il y a certaines
compétences qui n'ont de sens que porter
à plusieurs je pense aux mobilité on
pense évidemment au développement
économique on pense aux déchets ce que
vous disiez madame la Présidente on peut
penser au réseau d'assainissement ça n'a
pas de sens de les penser uniquement à
l'échelle d'une commune si vous faites
votre réseau d'assainissement mais que
ça s'arrête à la frontière de votre
commune vous aurez tout de même des
problèmes à la fin si votre voisin ne le
fait pas donc évidemment il y a des
problématiques qui se pensent ensemble
et je pense que au-delà on a besoin que
l'interco soit dans une compétence
d'appui avec une grande souplesse
d'action
ça c'est le premier point entre
guillemets dans la relation avec les
intercos en tout cas c'est celle que
nous prenons c'est celle que nous
développons dans un certain nombre de
territoires
par ailleurs je pense que un des enjeux
majeurs pour pouvoir permettre aux
maires de réussir leur mission c'est
évidemment la question pour les petites
communes et peut-être se rince le cas
aussi pour les communes rurales mais les
moyens que on peut leur mettre à
disposition ne serait-ce qu'en termes
financier je vais pas refaire le couplet
je pense que vous en êtes convaincu sur
la mise à contribution et je dirais même
la mise sous tension des finances
publiques locales on a fortement mis à
contribution je crois autant de 46
milliards ces dernières années les
communes ce qui n'est pas sans poser des
questions on a quand même aujourd'hui
nous dans les études que l'on a fait
dans le cadre des études financières en
fin 2022 plus de 44% des maires qui ont
répondu à ce questionnaire qui nous
disait que eux s'interrogent du fait
dans le cadre de l'inflation par exemple
de fermer des équipements de service
public qui viendrait s'ajouter aux
fermetures qui existent déjà par l'État
notamment par les services hospitaliers
etc ce que nous ne voulons évidemment
pas dans ce contexte là on a vu se
développer au niveau de l'État un
fonctionnement par appel à projet c'est
à dire qu'on a supprimé des dotations je
rappelle simplement que les dotations
n'étaient pas des subventions de l'État
c'est parfois comme ça que ça puait être
précisé mais qui était vraiment des
compensations de fiscalité qui avait été
retiré dans les années 70 tu temps de
Valéry Giscard d'Estaing si ma mémoire
est bonne et aujourd'hui cette DGF a été
un peu décrite comme étant une
subvention de l'État aux communes et que
donc l'État avait plein loisirs de la
supprimer dans une vision assez
restrictive de ce qui était l'autonomie
financière des collectivités je dirais
strictive à la fois de la part des
gouvernements successifs et je le dis en
polémique mais également à mon sens du
juge constitutionnel ou à mon sens
réellement qui dit transmission de
compétences dit nécessairement aussi
transmission de la capacité à agir y
compris en termes de fiscalité et les
suppressions successives de leviers
fiscaux pour nous sont évidemment de
mauvaises nouvelles pour répondre à
l'instant T problématique mais même dans
notre capacité à nous adapter à l'avenir
aux problématiques que l'on rencontre
donc ça il y a ce premier aspect pour
faire face à ces baisses de dotation on
a vu l'état
remplacer ces dispositifs par des appels
à projets et ces appels à projets soyons
très clairs c'est quelque sorte une
subvention en tout cas une prime pour
les plus grandes communes parce qu'en
terme d'ingénierie notamment sans
vouloir être excessif mais quand vous
avez un appel à projet qui vous parvient
le vendredi où on vous demander de
répondre pour le lundi ou pour le mardi
évidemment si vous n'avez pas les
équipes c'est vous tout seul en tant que
mère qui vous retrouvez à le faire
pendant le week-end ça paraît peut-être
bête et méchant et très pratique ou
pratique mais concrètement ça fait que
beaucoup de communes renoncent ensuite à
déposer un projet et que donc à la fin
ce sont les plus grandes communes qui
ont bénéficié on a un exemple concret je
pense à la dotation de soutien
d'investissement local je crois que
c'est en Indre-et-Loire je parle sous le
contrôle mais où par exemple quasiment
enfin plus de 50% voire les deux tiers
du montant des cils qui étaient prévus
finalement été donné à la ville de Tours
ce qui est très bien pour la ville de
Tours mais qui est finalement la ville
centrale et donc les autres communes
autour on comprend doivent se partager
ce qu'il reste donc on voit bien et je
pense que c'était pas forcément une
volonté de l'État mais que c'est tout
simplement mécaniquement par ce système
d'appel à projet qu'on est Vince toute
une partie des plus petites communes et
y compris des communes des petites
villes mais qui sont pas si petites
parce que 25000 habitants dans un
territoire rural c'est une ville de
centralité enfin c'est une véritable
centralité je veux pas être trop long
mais j'ajouterais simplement dans les
moyens mis à disposition il y a la
question de l'ingénierie et là on
constate quand même un affaiblissement
en tout cas une dévitalisation
progressive de l'État déconcentré et moi
je pense que pour que la
décentralisation fonctionne il faut en
face aussi un état déconcentré en
capacité de répondre et le rôle de
l'État déconcentré en tant que Conseil
des Collectivités pour moi c'est
vraiment diminué avec une impression que
plus on réduit les moyens de l'état des
concentré plus finalement
c'est une logique assez il va se
reporter sur ses compétences de contrôle
y compris des sanctions donc on a un
rapport aussi qui commence peut-être à
être biaisé or je pense que l'instant
des parfums préfectoral à l'échelle
départementale j'entends et de la
sous-préfecture est un échange tout à
fait pertinent parce qu'il oblige aussi
l'état à s'adapter aux réalités et dans
mon département dans les Yvelines par
exemple évidemment quand vous êtes sous
préfet vous en rendez très vite compte
vous n'avez pas tout à fait la même
réaction si vous êtes dans la
sous-préfecture de Saint-Germain-en-Laye
une zone beaucoup plus dense
urbanistiquement ou si vous êtes dans la
zone de Rambouillet par exemple donc
c'est une évidence qui demande
évidemment pour moi à être maintenu donc
je sais que ça élargit peut-être le
spectre de votre réflexion mais je pense
quand même qu'il est important de penser
en commun des concentration
décentralisation
je terminerai simplement là-dessus c'est
qu'on voit pardon pour le pour le gros
mot pour ceux qui nous écoutent mais une
agenceification de l'état de plus en
plus d'agences qui sont développés sans
doute pour mettre en visibilité des
actions qui seraient menées mais la
réalité derrière c'est que souvent elle
reste très centralisée avec des
situations qui peuvent parfois
aller vers l'ubuesque je cite juste un
cas de figure que j'ai pu rencontrer
certains services de l'État vont vous
dire que une parcelle donnée sur votre
territoire doit faire l'objet d'une
densification forte et que donc vous
pouvez aller de l'avant donner des
permis que vous serez soutenu
financièrement sur ce projet et puis
vous avez d'autres services liés à
d'autres agences qui elles soient en
appel à leur hiérarchie nationale vous
disent ah non non c'est une zone
évidemment à protéger d'un point de vue
de la biodiversité notamment la
perspective du Zéro artificialisation
nette donc nous on se tourne évidemment
vers les services préfecture pour
comprendre quelle est la lecture qu'on
doit avoir aussi contradictoire sur le
même projet et on nous dit ah non non ce
sont deux demandes distinctes veuillez
les traiter comme tel distinctement je
me dis comment d'un côté puis-je avancer
sur des permis de construire et de
l'autre faire tout un axe de
préservation et de protection de cette
même parcelle je veux bien être
schizophrène mais dans une certaine
limite quand même donc je peux
comprendre qu'il y a des difficultés
finalement à créer cette cohésion mais
je pense que si l'instance de décision
infinie était celle de la préfecture en
tout cas dans l'analyse des dossiers
nous en sorte nous en sortirions pardon
collectivement renforcé avec une plus
grande capacité d'action et d'arbitrage
aussi pour les élus une fine et enfin je
termine simplement sur cette question
des agences je pense que si l'état
souhaitait maintenir cette politique sur
les agences il serait en tout cas
essentiel que les élus y ait une place
parce que le sentiment qu'on peut avoir
parfois c'est celle d'une des possession
et qu'à la fin notre capacité à être
dans un dialogue direct avec les
décideurs ou en tout cas ceux qui vont
analyser les dossiers et quasiment nulle
quand on nous renvoie systématiquement
finalement à des décisions prises à une
échelle plus haute à l'échelle nationale
on aurait encore mille choses à vous
dire mais comme j'ai déjà été long je me
permets de m'arrêter
très bien
merci
maintenant passez
la parole à Monsieur Carteret que qui
doit brancher son son micro si c'est si
c'est possible a priori
portable pour vous entendre du coup j'ai
loupé tout le début excusez-moi
j'ai pas entendu du tout le début
peut-être que mon collègue j'ai le gros
a entendu peut intervenir pour la MRS
tout ce que je viens d'entendre en tout
cas par rapport aux Yvelines
c'est pas tout à fait la ruralité qui
est la mienne quoi et dans nos rurales
ce que je sais c'est que pourra jamais
se passer du maire quoi et les communes
on s'est important de la proximité des
services de proximité dont on attend
besoin et c'est vrai que tous les
échanges
et les compétences un maximum de
compétences va pouvoir rester à la
liberté des communes de chacune des
communes rurales et Michel tu veux
continuer parce que j'ai pas entendu le
début j'ai peur d'être déphasé
excusez-moi pas de souci
très bien merci bonjour Jean-Paul et
merci de passer la parole bonjour à
toutes et à tous donc beaucoup de choses
ont été déjà par le premier intervenant
donc juste recadrer un petit peu
la MF l'AMRF des communes de moins de
3500 habitants donc il représente malgré
tout 33% de la population française et
qui couvre 80% du territoirement dit les
communes rurales sont en termes de
territoire en tout cas largement
majoritaire dans le pays pour autant on
constate depuis le les élections de 2020
pas moins de 900 mères ont déjà
démissionné et les mers ruraux sont
plutôt des durs à cuire et s'ils ont
démissionné c'est pour de bonnes raisons
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on ne comprend plus
il y a une perte de sens très forte de
démerdes vis-à-vis de les services de
l'État et vis-à-vis de la politique des
politiques qui sont menées et qui nous
font perdre le cap on sait plus vraiment
comment on peut gérer les communes il y
a une clairement de notre point de vue
en tout cas un manque de visibilité dans
les politiques publiques un manque de
continuité on a le sentiment que les
choses changent très très vite et non
pas qu'on soit plus bête que les autres
aussi s'adapter également mais il ne
meurent pas moins que les choses
changent beaucoup trop vite pour qu'on
puisse construire une politique sur le
long terme dans nos communes il a été il
a été évoqué tout à l'heure les agences
de l'État effectivement je peux revenir
tout à l'heure où on passe de la NCT
après c'est le fond vert après c'est
d'autres l'ADN et pour les communes
rurales si vous voulez sans ingénierie
c'est une c'est une difficulté
supplémentaire
on peut constater avec beaucoup
d'amertume cette marche forcée vers
l'intercommunalité je rappelle
simplement que à tous les collègues mais
je pense que vous le savez bien que les
terres communales
les maires ont su déjà sur regroupés
depuis très longtemps pour faire des
choses ensemble et ainsi mutualiser les
moyens et être plus efficaces mais ce
qu'on constate aujourd'hui depuis la loi
neutre avec cette frange forcée vers
l'intercommunalité
conduit à une perte de sang c'est
surtout renfort renforcement des des
communes centre des intercommunalités au
détriment des des communes rurales et ça
c'est on le voit à peu près dans toutes
les intercommunalités sauf si le
président ou la présidente de
l'intercommunalité et maire d'une
communauté rurale
mais malheureusement la plupart du temps
les présidents d'intercommunalités sont
les prix sont les nerfs des communes
centre et donc du coup on voit très bien
que les villes centre se développent
s'aménagent s'améliore au détriment des
communes rurales donc la péréquation ou
le partage des richesses entre la ville
sainte et les communes rurales
n'est pas forcément
au rendez-vous
[Musique]
le on pourrait parler mais je brosse
rapidement un tableau après on pourra
peut-être revenir si vous avez des
questions
à la DGF ou c'est un combat que nous
menons que les merveuaux mènent depuis
de longues années et pour faire simple
en euros par habitant une commémorale et
c'est 64 euros par habitant alors qu'une
commune urbaine c'est sa étude euros par
habitant alors que aujourd'hui
les charges de centralité qui étaient à
l'époque supporté par les villes centre
sont aujourd'hui
majoritairement transférés aux
intercommunalités et donc cette
différence de au niveau de la DGF
un urbain vaut 2 ruraux et on l'a dit
non depuis des années sauf qu'on il
semblerait qu'on ne soit pas entendu et
je voudrais reprendre les mots qui nous
ont été
donnés il y a pas très longtemps par le
cabinet de madame la Première ministre
lorsqu'on lui a posé la question sur la
réforme de la DGF la réponse qui nous a
été donnée c'est pas possible nous avons
perdu les clés de la formule donc ça
c'est pas quelque chose qui nous
satisfait et c'est de nature également à
démotiver les collègues
la complexification des subventions
nous avons des partenaires financiers
dans les dans les communes que sont la
plupart du temps
la région et les départements du moindre
mesure les intercommunalités mais en
tout cas d'aller deux premières
structures que j'ai cité les demandes de
subvention sont simples il n'y a pas de
difficulté on dépose les dossiers les
dossiers une fois qu'ils sont montés on
est aidé par les services de la région
et du département et du coup nos
subventions peuvent nous être attribués
il n'avait pas du tout les mêmes cas au
niveau de l'État ou les subventions sont
soumises à des critères et surtout et
pire que tout c'est qu'elles sont
soumises à des à des taux qui sont
variables en fonction
je dirais presque du bon vouloir du
préfet je siège en tant que président
des mers euros du Var je siège à la
commission DETR
et il a fallu que je fasse un monde les
conditions d'attribution pour que il y
ait un petit recentrage de la DETR sur
les territoires ruraux parce que tels
que la délétère est définie aujourd'hui
dotation d'équipement des territoires
ruraux tel qu'elle est définie
aujourd'hui la DETR peut bénéficier à
des communes de 20000 habitants
sous réserve qu'elles aient un potentiel
fiscal etc etc mais il ne meurt pas
moins que ces strates et je pose les pas
les urbains contre les bureaux ces
strates de communes ont d'autres moyens
de financement auxquelles nous les
communes rurales nous n'avons pas accès
donc la dotation d'équipement des
territoires ruraux doit être en priorité
concentré sur les communes et la
complexification des conditions
d'attribution de ces dotations par
l'État fait que très souvent
ça rend les les projets
inéligibles pour les communes rurales
et donc elle perde de la capacité à
faire aménager leur commune
au musée il nous demande également des
projets qui sont de plus en plus
complexes et ça ça a été déjà évoqué par
le collègue tout à l'heure
il nous manque cruellement de
l'ingénierie et c'est pas en nous disant
la NCT à tout bout de champ quand on
arrivera à avancer la NCT pour la
plupart des communes rurales c'est un
numéro de téléphone ou
un contact qui vous renvoie de postes en
poste jusqu'à ce que vous arrivez
jusqu'à ce qu'ils arrivent à vous
décourager et que vous raccrochez
le notre problématique très importante
pour les communes rurales c'est
également le délai alors je suis très
pratique mais ce sont les délais de
paiement entre de la dota du décilitre
très souvent pour des projets un peu
significatifs les communautés rurales
sont mises en difficulté puisque nous
devons sortir les fonds pour payer les
entreprises qui ont réalisé les travaux
et à côté de ça l'État met 7 à 8 mois à
payer les communes avec tout un tas de
tracasseries administratives ça a été
brièvement évoqué par le collègue tout à
l'heure et je dois dire que je rebondis
volontiers là-dessus
il y a également les problèmes plus
généraux qui sont les liés au zéro
artificialisation nette ou les communes
rurales dans la grande majorité ont été
plutôt des bons élèves à la matière or
aujourd'hui la manière dont la loi
s'applique de manière latérale on va
pénaliser autant les communes qui ont
été des bons élèves que les communes qui
l'ont été moins alors j'ai pas de
jugement de valeur à ce que je dis mais
il ne meurt pas moins que regard
différentiel serait probablement
intéressant
il y a un point sur lequel nous mettons
nous avons nous saluons les opérations
cœur de ville ou bien le dispositif
petite ville de demain sauf que
aujourd'hui nous luttons alors même si
après avoir rencontré Madame la ministre
Dominique Faure et Monsieur le Ministre
Christophe Béchu il semblerait que des
positions qui évoluent mais nous on
souhaiterait vraiment qu'il y ait un
dispositif d'ingénierie particulier pour
ce qu'on appelle on souhaiterait appeler
village d'avenir
et qui pourrait être les anciens les
anciens chefs de camieu cantons ou les
communes rurales ou les maires on ne
volonté de rentrer dans ce dispositif
afin de développer les communes de
manière intelligente je peux y revenir
le souhaiter si vous souhaitez
on souhaiterait la pérennisation et
l'inscription dans la loi des etre
aujourd'hui on semblerait on a fait une
audition avec le préfet Phill ISO qui
est en charge de la définition de ces
adrrz plus on aimerait bien que ça ce
soit validé de manière
[Musique]
permanente pour connait une visibilité
sur le long terme et non pas naviguer à
vue comme nous le faisons aujourd'hui et
en fait je voudrais je voudrais terminer
par deux points
nous souhaiterions également que ça a
été brièvement évoqué le problème de
l'eau
pour la plupart du temps l'eau
les terres agricoles et la forêt c'est
dans les territoires européens
et donc ces aménités rurales les
services rendus par la nature au profit
du plus grand nombre ne sont pas prises
en compte dans le calcul des dotations
d'État or
de dire que en ce qui me concerne par
exemple à l'époque où j'aurais pu le
faire il m'aurait été plus efficace de
bétonner 500 hectares de ma planète
agricole dans ma commune pour faire un
Ikea plutôt que de faire une zone
agricole protégée sauf qu'aujourd'hui la
zone agricole protégée elle permet de
capter stocker l'eau nourrir la
population et puis la forêt stocke le
carbone que nous n'avons pas émis donc
ces services écosystémiques rendus par
la nature que nous les communes les
communes rurales nous nous maintenons
l'eau l'agriculture les terres agricoles
et la forêt il me semble qu'en tout cas
ça devrait être reconnu comme quelque
chose d'important est mis dans la
Constitution à travers la notion
d'espace et enfin le dernier point et là
je pense que je peux rejoindre
l'ensemble des collègues autour de la
table
on constate hélas un changement dans le
comportement de nos admin qui loin
d'être alors je caricature pas et je ne
mets pas tout le monde en même panier
mais il ne meurt pas moins que on
constate que nos administrer ne sont
plus des citoyennes mais plus sincères
plus globalement des consommateurs et ça
rend la gestion d'une commune très
difficile voilà après bien entendu je
vais laisser la parole à mon col mon
collègue Jean-Paul et puis
c'est très récent cette information par
exemple la DSR a été surtout orientée
vers les bourses et
au détriment des communes qui ne sont
pas bourses et ça c'est c'est un signe
de vouloir concentrer dans les
territoires ce qui ne devrait pas l'être
mais au contraire
davantage maillé le territoire Michel
c'est bien Michel de Dieu partage tout
ce que tu as dit et je voudrais préciser
que
on a trop tendance à identifier un
périmètre de vie les communautés de
communes surtout depuis que ça a été à
marche forcée vers des fusions de
communauté on a plusieurs bassins de vie
dans une communauté et je souhaiterais
mais nous souhaitons qu'un raisonnement
évolue vers
comment prendre en considération les
bassins de vie un bassin de vie pour moi
c'est un périmètre de scolarisation par
exemple c'est une unité de vie quand il
y a 11 villages qui mettent les enfants
dans une école concentrée par exemple ou
des concentré qu'importe ça définit
territorialement un bassin de vie et
dans une communauté de communion il y en
a plusieurs et quand on veut faire vivre
tout le monde de la même façon dans une
com comme ça ne marche pas les gens ne
se connaissent pas d'un bout à l'autre
de cette communauté de communes dans les
territoires les plus ruraux et il est
grand temps aujourd'hui comprennent en
considération ces bassins de vie dans
chaque bassin de vie et je voudrais bien
c'est une de mes contributions pour
France ruralité
égale agenda 2
il s'agirait de de faire en sorte que
dans chaque bassin de vie il y a une
école bien sûr il y a quelque chose je
dis quelque chose parce que on est
tellement sous considéré parfois par
rapport à la santé par rapport au
service public et ça signifierait la
proximité quand on va à l'école on fait
c'est il vient d'y avoir par exemple il
y a pas très longtemps une aide à la
relance de commerce
bien on va pas mettre un commerce au
milieu de nulle part tout comme on va
pas mettre un médecin au milieu de nulle
part il faut qu'il y ait l'addition de
tout dans chacun des bassins de vie
j'aurais fait défini par un périmètre de
scolarisation des enfants de l'école
primaire ça c'est une chose je plaide
aussi puisque je représente les mers
euros dans la filière petite enfance je
plaide pour un service public d'un petit
enfant ça la périphérie de chaque école
dans les territoires ruraux pourquoi
parce que quand il y a il y a de moins
en moins vous le savez tous
d'assistante maternelle parce que le
métier est trop déjà est mal payé être
en prenant avec des employeurs pas
toujours facile etc et on a cette amitié
en tension tout le monde le sait donc
aujourd'hui on a recours à un service
public de la petite enfance
il y a des crèches et des microcèches
mais quand elles sont éloignées d'un bon
centre ou éloignés
d'un village d'avenir comme la bien dit
Michel il y a des villages où il y a
des services mais pas de service public
de la petite enfance et si on ne fait
pas le pari on vient de le vivre avec la
carte scolaire avec des fermetures
d'école un peu partout s'il y a pas de
quoi renouveler les enfants à l'école
c'est à dire de quoi inciter les jeunes
parents à s'installer près d'une école
assurément cette école là n'ira pas très
loin donc aujourd'hui
cette concentration
exacerbée vers les bourses vers les PVD
etc c'est que d'une PVD à l'autre
ça va se vider si on n'est pas réactif
et on doit prendre en considération tous
ces territoires ruraux qui m'aillent
bien le territoire qui donne de la
proximité
tous ces points doivent être pris en
considération je crois parier sur
l'avenir pariez sur les services publics
mais partout pas que dans les cercles
l'état nous a entendus en disant on va
déconcentrer on va donner leur sens au
territoire sauf que guerre après arrive
à dispositif PVD
et aujourd'hui on concentre dans les PVD
on a fait une erreur je fais partie de
cela d'ailleurs on a fait une erreur et
une trentaine d'années quand on a créé
les zones artisanales et on constate 20
ans plus tard que tout le monde s'est
installé autour des zones artisanales on
aurait mieux fait je crois de permettre
à des artisans de s'installer dans les
villages de on aurait fait de la mixité
moi j'ai été directeur d'école je vous
le dis en territoire très rural très
très rural j'avais dans ma classe de
tout des enfants d'agriculteurs des
enfants d'artisans des enfants de il y
avait un médecin aussi il y avait des
gens qui ne travaillaient pas etc il y
avait un vrai une vraie mixité sociale
aujourd'hui dans les territoires les
plus ruraux il n'y a plus de mixité
sociale on doit revenir à une mixité
sociale si on veut donner de l'avenir au
territoire et du coup
dans chaque village où le maire est le
référent et le premier maillon de la
chaîne sociale on l'a bien vécu avec le
la période covid premier maillon de la
chaîne sociale premier agent de la scène
de sécurité aujourd'hui on installe des
référents par rapport aux violences
intra familiales qui sont les plus
développés dans les territoires ruraux
souvent en tout cas c'est le cas d'un
autre département et et aujourd'hui si
on ne garantit pas cette proximité avec
le maire et son conseil municipal avec
des élus qui sont là au quotidien y
compris le week-end jour la nuit le jour
les mers euro c'est un jour et nuit 24
heures sur 24 on est à disposition de
nos habitants on est près d'eux ils
viennent nous voir etc
je plaide aussi pour ces France services
qui ont été bien vu également elmaille
le territoire au plus près un peu plus
près que le
siège de la Communauté de Communes
et qu'on vise à défendre le premier
maillon de la chaîne publique qui est le
secrétariat américain qui est la mairie
aujourd'hui on veut mettre en place des
plateformes pour les recueils
passeport et carte d'identité pour que
les gens puissent prendre le rendez-vous
directement non il faut passer par la
mairie parce que si on commence à faire
ça on dira après mais pourquoi il y a
besoin des mairies non il faut pas
la mairie doit c'est vraiment le point
de référence pour chacun des habitants
qui peut y aller à pied mes parents
étaient dans une commune qui a été
fusionnée par les lois Marcellin je le
donne souvent en exemple
au début c'était amer délégué il y avait
un maire dans chaque hameau mais 20 ans
plus tard il y a plus de merde dans
chaque hameau les mairies des hameaux
sont fermés et bien ma mère elle
n'allait plus voter parce qu'il fallait
qu'elle aille à 5 km dans le bourse et
moi je ne veux pas de ça la ruralité
c'est pas ça et la ruralité elle mérite
davantage de respect parce que nous
sommes sur 88% du territoire avec 33% de
la population c'est à prendre en
considération au quotidien un mot enfin
les communes rurales contribuent très
nettement à l'économie locale je préside
en alternance avec le président de la NF
une année sur deux la commission de TR
chaque année je fais remarquer que 65%
de l'enveloppe detpr a été consommé par
des communes rurales
je répète 65% de l'enveloppe de TR est
consommée par les communes rurales en
plus on fait travailler l'artisan local
parce que c'est c'est des chantiers qui
sont pas démesurés et des réparations
c'est des maisons aussi des beaux
chantiers de restructuration
porté par nos communaux rurales les
communautés de communes consomment 23%
de la DETR ça veut dire qu'une fois ça
veut dire qu'elles ont moins de réserves
d'excédent de fonctionnement avec toutes
ces indemnités avec toutes ces chefs de
service poursuit chef de service pour ça
des salaires etc que nous on n'a pas
parce que on a des bénévoles en plus
aidez-vous pour nos habitants à côté
d'eux voilà appelez
merci
beaucoup peut-être pour les pour les
intervenants suivants et peut-être
pourrons-nous revenir sur les propos qui
ont été tenus
si vous pouvez illustrer très très
concrètement alors vous l'avez fait sur
certains sujets mais je vais prendre
l'exemple de l'intercommunalité quand de
deux intervenants précédents ont
souligné le fait qu'il fallait que les
communes et peut-être un peu plus de
compétences au sein du bloc communal ce
qui serait bien c'est de qualifier ses
compétences et que vous puissiez nous
dire quelles compétences parce que pour
nous c'est essentiel je veux dire on
peut pas rester sur quelque chose de
trop général l'objet de cette mission
d'information c'est vraiment
notamment dans un dans un temps et un
moment où on arrive à une forme de
maturité de l'intercommunalité d'avoir
votre regard très clair très précis sur
celle des compétences qui sont dites
peut-être plus plus stratégiques qui
s'exerce justement à l'échelle
communautaire et puis celle qui relève
plus de la proximité que vous jugez
comme étant des compétences qui doivent
revenir
aux communes et puis j'insiste un peu
sur sur ce que j'avais évoqué mais là
aussi c'est important on entend bien le
propos sur l'avenir de la commune il y a
un deuxième volet sur notre mission
c'est l'avenir des maires peut-être nous
dire aussi
quels sont les écueils que vous
rencontrez quels sont les sujets sur
lesquels il faudrait que nous puissions
évoluer sur les conditions d'exercices
de vos mandats locaux je pense notamment
à un sujet dont on va débattre au Sénat
dans quelques jours sur la question
notamment des secrétaires de mairie sur
la question des du statut de l'élu
surtout ces sujets là n'hésitez pas
aussi à en parler parce que c'est bien
les deux piliers de de la mission qui
est qui est la nôtre et puis
pardon d'un insister mais vraiment sur
la vision pros on a bien compris
qu'elles étaient aujourd'hui les freins
dans l'exercice de vos mandats
respectifs dans la vision que vous aviez
vous-même de de la commune on va essayer
aussi de traiter la relation entre le
citoyen et la commune mais on
souhaiterait aussi avoir pouvoir prendre
le pouls et avoir votre votre vision
votre sentiment sur ce que doit être et
on c'est pour ça qu'on l'a précise dans
les questionnaires qu'on vous a adressé
la commune demain après demain d'ici
2030 notamment parce que tout ce qui
vient d'être dit on le partage on a
souvent porté les les sujets que vous
évoquiez notamment la question des de
cette politique
d'agentilisation vous disiez monsieur le
monsieur le Maire que la detr65% de la
DETR il faudrait que ce soit 100% de la
DETR qui aille au commune rurale puisque
c'est la définition de la DETR et nous
l'avons reprécisé dans un projet de loi
de finance récent ici au Sénat donc
voilà c'est c'est vraiment des des des
sujets et puis on passe qu'on va
s'adresser à des associations d'élus de
communes plus importantes les c'est les
mêmes questions c'est à dire quelle est
la quelle est la place du maire de la
commune aujourd'hui quand bien même on
est une ville centre donc c'est bien
parce qu'on aura ce matin un peu les les
deux volets et les deux visions de de la
commune mais pour nous voilà c'est c'est
vraiment toutes ces questions tous ces
sujets qui nous intéressent en ayant
vraiment le maximum de précisions dans
ce que vous vivez au quotidien et encore
une fois comme on s'intéressera
nécessairement au bloc communal puisque
c'est c'est le cœur du du sujet de notre
mission
quelle est dans les rapports que vous
avez avec l'intercommunalité et je
m'empresse de dire que ça a été un des
postulats de départ il ne s'agit pas de
pour nous d'opposer communes à
intercommunalité mais peut-être de se
dire que comme je le disais à l'instant
il est important de voir quels sont pour
demain les compétences qui ont plus
vocation à relever de la proximité donc
de la commune et celle stratégique ou de
mutualisation qui doivent à
l'intercommunalité voilà je sais pas
les trois les trois mères qui viennent
ils représentants d'associations qui
viennent de s'exprimer si vous voulez un
mot là-dessus parce que je sais que
Monsieur cornalba doit partir et puis
après on laissera les deux autres
associations d'élus exprimées
[Musique]
juste on va laisser monsieur cornalba
parce qu'il doit nous quitter d'ici
quelques minutes
merci beaucoup et ça prouve toute la
coopération entre petite ville et ville
rurale et je vous remercie parce que
effectivement je me retrouve dans
beaucoup de choses qui ont pu être dites
et vraiment y compris au sein de la PVF
on a évidemment toute une part des
communes membres qui sont elles-mêmes
vraiment très attaché je dirais à cet
agenda rural qu'il faut qu'on construise
ensemble donc je m'y retrouve tout à
fait pour répondre à la question
notamment interco ville et donc
l'évolution de ce bloc communal dans son
ensemble il y a une chose qu'on a on n'a
pas précisé mais pour moi c'est que ça a
été dit ça a été à marche forcée il y a
eu beaucoup de réticences et évidemment
enfin je suis maire depuis 2020 et je
vois bien en tout cas mes collègues qui
ont pu être élu avant souvent me disent
autrefois c'était différent on avait
plus de latitude c'est un carcan
j'entends totalement ce discours
néanmoins j'ai tendance à penser que dès
lors que l'interco existe il faut faire
en sorte qu'elle soit utiles parce que
pour les citoyens c'est incompréhensible
qui puisse y avoir des échelons et des
instances qui se réuniraient sans qu'on
en voit concrètement le produit et c'est
là où je pense que une chose qui
pourrait peut-être nous réunir c'est que
pour moi une intercommunalité n'a de
sens que si elle a un projet territoire
or souvent encore on a un certain nombre
d'intercaux qui ne développe pas de
projet de territoire moi je pense que il
faudrait rendre cela absolument
impératif parce que par rapport à ce qui
a été dit sur l'absence parfois les gens
ne se connaissent pas toujours quand on
a des interco XXL c'est vrai on dépasse
parfois des bassins de territoire des
bassins de vie et donc il faut un
minimum qu'il y ait un projet territoire
qui puisse se dire mais qu'est-ce qu'on
a envie de faire ensemble ne serait-ce
que se poser s'obliger dans l'année qui
suit les élections à se dire bon bah
très bien on a tous été élu sur des
programmes on a tous des ambitions et
qui souvent peuvent se rejoindre sur un
certain nombre de politiques qu'est-ce
qu'on veut faire ensemble et quel est
les moyens que l'on va se donner à voir
ensuite les modalités pour l'adoption
d'un tel document pour s'assurer que ne
soit pas oublié les plus petites
communes dans des intercos comme ça a
été dit qui peuvent parfois être présidé
par par la commune centre qui voudrait
peut-être tracer sa route seul on peut
être que là il y a matière à trouver des
équilibres pour aussi obliger chacun à
prendre en considération aussi la
situation des plus petites communes dans
une dans une intercom mais là je pense
qu'il y a vraiment une chose à
développer le deuxième point où je vois
une plus-value pour l'interco par
exemple c'est sur les financements et je
pense au Fonds européen je veux pas
qu'on oublie ce point là c'est un point
important on n'y pense pas toujours
souvent on a l'impression quand on parle
fonds européen d'avoir face à nous une
montagne et on n'ose pas en tant que
petite commune y aller je pense que ça
peut être l'intérêt d'une interco de
mutualiser la capacité d'ingénierie à
aller chercher ses financements là c'est
vrai que ma commune 5000 habitants quand
bien même on a des agents très
compétents c'est vrai qu'on n'a jamais
fait du Fonds européen et on se sent
parfois impuissant je sais qu'à
l'échelle d'une interco on se sentirait
davantage de le faire on a été plus ou
moins obligé par le passé dans les un
contrat de transition écologique et
contrat de relance et transition
écologique un crtu notamment à fait
remonter au niveau de l'interconno
projet on s'est aperçu parfois cette
occasion un peu par hasard jamais de
dire qu'on avait des projets similaires
sur la végétalisation sur les sites
scolaires voilà il y avait un certain
nombre de projets sur la rénovation
thermique qui prient individuellement
n'aurait eu quasiment aucune chance
d'aboutir au niveau européen mais qui
mis ensemble peuvent avoir le poids
suffisant pour intéresser aussi des
financeurs à un échelon à plus haut là
je vois très concrètement un intérêt
potentiel pour l'intercommunalité
maintenant je rejoins totalement ce qui
a été dit sur le fait que la commune
c'est le filet social de base c'est le
guichet de base des citoyens quand on ne
sait pas où aller quand on a une
difficulté quelconque on ne sait pas
toujours qui du département qui de telle
agence de Pôle Emploi etc et responsable
d'un sujet et donc bien souvent on va
d'abord à la communauté donc la commune
c'est le guichet qui ensuite réoriente
mais ce qui est souvent les personnes
ont l'impression que je peux dire que la
Mairie est responsable de tout mais
presque alors on parlait tout à l'heure
du fait par il y avait un côté
consommateur qui pouvait exister et dans
tous les cas les gens vont en mairie et
je le constate ça a été le cas pendant
la crise covid ça a été le cas aussi
dans l'accueil des réfugiés
jésus-christiens quand les personnes ont
voulu aider quand ils ne savaient pas
quoi faire c'est en mairie qu'ils sont
allés et je me souviens que le lendemain
de l'agression russe de l'Ukraine le
lendemain nous avions des personnes qui
arrivaient avec des sacs de nourriture
etc en mairie ça pouvait surprendre mais
ça prouve que le réflexe de base c'est
de se tourner vers la mairie et je pense
que dans les réformes à venir c'est loi
exister cette dimension là ne devrait
pas être oubliée parce que ça c'est
vraiment au plus concret j'ajouterai un
deuxième aspect à mon avis absolument
concret pour la pour les mairies qui à
mon avis est un rôle à défendre
qu'à l'échelle d'une interco on pense un
aménagement du territoire je l'entends
il y a des choses qui doivent se penser
à plusieurs je les dis tout à l'heure
sur les plans vélo sur les mobilités sur
l'assainissement sur les déchets etc je
pense malgré tout que un certain nombre
de problématiques d'urbanisme relèvent
quand même aussi infinie des communes
parce que il y a des équilibres à
préserver que ce soit en termes de
patrimoine en termes d'aménagement de
sensibilité aussi
de la population sur sur place en
quelque sorte de nos habitants que seul
un maire qui est finalement ça a été dit
par votre président est à portée de
baffes ou d'engueulades parfois c'était
cool à nous on peut l'avoir aussi et
donc ça permet peut-être d'avoir une
plus grande finesse dans les
aménagements urbanistiques et de savoir
ce qui serait accepté de ce qui ne
serait pas et je pense que dans une
agglo ou dans une communauté de
communique sixl si toutes les décisions
d'urbanisme devaient être remontées à
cet échange là je pense qu'on va au
devant parfois de certaines catastrophes
en termes d'urbanisme qu'on regretterait
amèrement ensuite
l'ultime point avant de m'éclipser
vraiment navré de devoir vous quitter
plus tôt je veux juste pas qu'on oublie
les aspects RH
les questions de ressources humaines
souvent on oublie de les évoquer ça a
été dit un tout petit peu en filigrane
par l'association des mers ruraux mais
sur la question de l'attractivité des
emplois territoriaux si on veut aussi en
termes d'ingénierie augmenter la
capacité la compétence il y a quand même
un levier salarial qui est important
qu'il faut pas oublier peut-être que
parfois le commune le plus grande taille
en cette plus grande capacité à aller
chercher ses compétences là en
rémunérant davantage on est parfois nous
petite commune bloquée sur cet aspect là
donc là je pense aussi que dans les
problématiques salariales en termes de
revalorisation salariale pour parler
clairement je pense que là il y a un
véritable enjeu ce qui implique
nécessairement si ces décisions sont
prises et que d'accompagner les communes
pour pouvoir le faire très concrètement
mais je crois réellement qu'il y a un
décrochage qui s'est fait petit à petit
petit à petit dans le temps et qui fait
que des métiers qui pouvaient être
attractifs qui ont plus été valorisant
parce qu'il y avait une vraie
reconnaissance et un vrai sentiment
d'utilité publique petit à petit sont
devenus moins attractifs aussi pour
cette raison salariale là et donc
ensuite on a une fuite des cerveaux une
fuite des capacités des compétences
parfois vers d'autres secteurs y compris
parfois éloignés de l'intérêt général et
ça je crois que attaché au service
public que nous sommes nous ne pouvons
que le regretter et c'est aussi entre
nos mains d'y répondre merci beaucoup
la parole ensuite au représentant de
ville de France
la parole à Monsieur Carteret je crois
qui souhaitait ajouter
quelques éléments
concrets de choses qui
peuvent aller mieux quand c'est géré
dans avec davantage de proximité je
resterai cohérent par rapport au
périmètre de scolarisation des enfants
par exemple
et quand on nous dit notre école faisons
là ensemble c'est ce que je souhaite le
ministre actuellement comment quand on a
quatre ou cinq écoles sur une communauté
de communes on peut faire notre école
ensemble
on va c'est pas possible on peut pas
avoir le même projet si on veut mettre
autour
d'un bassin de vie les enseignants la
vie économique la vie associative etc
c'est pas la même chose que dans le
bassin de vie d'un côté donc forcément
il y a des compétences aujourd'hui on
devrait
réoriser je crois parce que on est
capable de le faire on a prouvé dans le
passé avec les syndicats plutôt que de
supprimer syndicats on devrait autoriser
on l'appellera autrement si il faut des
conventions des partenariats etc et pour
sauver les territoires ruraux je crois
qu'il faut autoriser les communes à
travailler ensemble
je reviens toujours à mon terme de
bassin de vie et les syndicats je répète
ont fait leurs preuves voilà un exemple
dans ma communauté de communes la loi
notre fait vous le savez très bien que
la composition d'un représentations des
communes plus la commune est grande plus
la représentant donc moi dans ma
communauté par exemple
trois communes
sur 60 et quelques représentants trois
communes en ont 26
c'est à dire que elle décide quasiment
tout on peut pas s'il faut 27 communes
autre pour pouvoir contrebalancer ce
pouvoir des communes les plus les plus
grandes ta montre ça ne marche pas quoi
il faut revenir à quelque chose de plus
équilibré
je ne la comme elle est très utile le
collègue de la petite ville qui
s'exprimer avant a bien su le dire il y
a des compétences qu'on peut partager ça
a été dit mais il y a alors chez nous
c'est trois grosses communes ont plaidé
pour le transfert de la compétence
voirie
alors depuis que depuis que la
compétence voirie est transférée les
travaux au lieu de se faire en début
d'année se font en fin d'année parce
qu'il y a les appels d'offres c'est des
gros chantiers c'est même pas les
entreprises de la comme qui enlèvent le
marché etc donc
laissons les communes on leur a enlevé
la capacité d'initiative plus évoquer
aussi j'ai Mappy vous voulez des
exemples depuis que la compétence de
force a été transférée à la à le PCI
les rivières ne sont plus entretenues
alors qu'avant avec des syndicats même
avec des communes on faisait chacun
l'entretien de de on a des ponts
aujourd'hui qui sont envahis d'arbres de
branches plus personne ne s'en occupe
parce qu'il y a un impôt dédié à cela et
que personne n'ose le mettre donc ça ne
se fait pas
voilà des exemples si vous en voulez et
j'en aurai d'autres mais je veux pas
abuser du montant de parole d'autant
plus qu'en plus je dois vous quitter
vers 9h45
merci beaucoup monsieur gros un petit
mot et puis après on passe à ville de
France
oui merci donc rebondir tout ce qui est
naître le
si vous voulez pour être tout à fait
alors presque provocateur mais en tout
cas direct
[Musique]
faut arrêter le double discours soit les
communes sont inutiles et à ce moment-là
on les supprime et on le dit soit les
communes sont utiles et à ce moment-là
on les laisse vivre et aujourd'hui on se
retrouve un peu dans des discours qui
sont différents des actes alors les
discours nous dit
un discours parfois un peu lénifiant de
la part de l'État et quand il est à ce
sens-là c'est-à-dire je ne cible pas le
gouvernement actuel je suis élu depuis
2008 et j'ai vu depuis 2008 un discours
un peu formaté qui arrive et qui est je
dirais qui dépasse largement les élus
qui se sont succédés depuis donc soit
les communes sont inutiles et à ce
moment-là il faut le dire on les
supprime soit de les communes sont
utiles à ce moment-là leur donne les
moyens on les aide dans les soutiens où
on est déjà irresponsable et on dilapide
on gaspille l'argent public et auquel
cas il faut plus nous en donner soit
aussi aménagé un territoire et à ce
moment-là il faut nous aider et c'est ce
double discours je trouve qui est
aujourd'hui et enfin qui n'est pas que
d'aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
qui est très difficile à accepter de la
part des des communes et notamment des
communes rurales parce qu'en fait les
élus
du gouvernement en gros nous disent non
on compte sur vous on a besoin de VOUS
sauf que derrière la techno structure
nous fait sentir que c'est pas bien
parler à 25 communes c'est plus
compliqué que que si on parle qu'à une
seule jambe pour preuve les les divers
proposants mais ça a été fait encore une
fois dans les gouvernements précédents
les propos récents de madame la Première
ministre qui
s'adressait aux intercommunalités au
propos de le zéro artificialisation
nette plutôt que commune alors que ça
concerne principalement les communes et
comme je le disais tout à l'heure nous
sommes plutôt les communes rurales nous
sommes plutôt des communes vertueuses en
termes de respect et de l'espace et
surtout de d'aménagement du territoire
donc c'est ce double discours qui était
insupportable et que nous n'avions plus
à accepter
on nous dit vous êtes utile pas les
moyens on vous dit on nous dit vous êtes
utile mais on transfère la majorité des
compétences en marche forcée dans
l'intercommunalité et c'est ça la
difficulté c'est que nous on veut bien
transférer les compétences et comme je
disais tout à l'heure on n'a pas attendu
que l'État nous le dise pour nous
regrouper et en syndicat ou en
communauté de communes mais on le fait
quand ça voulait dire quelque chose
quand derrière il y avait un véritable
projet or aujourd'hui tout ça ça arrive
d'en haut et ça nous ça descend jusque
dans les communes sans faire sans faire
comme un virage une analyse fine de ce
qu'il en est donc laissez-nous
travailler laissez-nous faire les choses
jugez-nous sur les résultats et non pas
par anticipation on a également dans les
territoires ruraux des communes qui
savent faire beaucoup de choses
le statut de l'élus a été évoqué le
statut l'élu aujourd'hui on en parle
comment comment peut-on avoir des
territoires ruraux ou autres dynamiques
mais plus fréquemment euro dynamique
avec des jeunes qui va s'investir dans
le mandat local quand on voit les
difficultés qui sont mises par rapport à
la mise à disponibilité de d'un seul
employeur quand on voit le la précarité
du statut des lieux où on est
responsable de tout et on est on n'a pas
beaucoup de couverture quand les
indemnités des élus et il y a pas j'ai
pas honte d'en parler parce qu'il y a
des indemnités d'élus qui sont
absolument ridicules on a on a une
vice-présidente la MRF qui a dû se
mettre en arrêt maladie pour pouvoir
continuer à
[Musique]
mener son mandat donc tout ça c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué dans une
communion rurale que dans une commune où
il y a du personnel il en est de même
pour tout ce qui concerne le montage des
dossiers l'ingénierie ça a été évoqué
c'est principalement le maire qui s'y
colle et puis enfin dernier point ils
vont pas être trop long et je peux
développer encore une fois si vous le
souhaitez
ça a été dit quand nos administrer ont
une question le premier réflexe c'est de
venir à la mairie
mais quelle est la réponse que l'on peut
leur apporter la première chose Monsieur
le Maire les poubelles ça déborde mais
c'est pas moi c'est l'intercommunalité
Monsieur le Maire quand est-ce que les
réseaux d'eau vont être séparés bah
c'est pas moi c'est
le maire le quand est-ce que les etc etc
l'urbanisme etc donc vous voyez bien que
ce double discours de dire c'est les
maires en première ligne mais derrière
c'est pas nous qui gérons ça
décrédibilise et on en vient une des
questions qui dans votre questionnaire
le taux de participation du
renouvellement des élections municipales
à brutalement chuteaux chuté parce que
on ne voit plus la pertinence d'un maire
dans les communes rurales voilà merci de
m'avoir écouté merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup on va passer maintenant à
ville de France je sais pas qui souhaite
commencer monsieur Shiro ou monsieur
strowman
merci à toi Eric et j'espère je pense
que nous serons complémentaires sur ce
que nous allons dire
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur mais mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs merci d'abord de
l'attention que vous nous portez et que
vous portez à la commune dont je sais
nous savons que vous êtes les défenseurs
au quotidien j'ai noté d'ailleurs que à
bon nombre d'entre vous avait été maire
et donc les sujets dont nous vous
parlons ne vous sont pas inconnus ville
de France était effectivement sur une
strate différente des
communes rurales nous aurons beaucoup de
sujets en commun et puis quelques
nuances évidemment sans que ce soit des
différences marquées ville de France si
je ne m'abuse correspond aux communes
entre 10000 et 100 000 habitants aux
communes et à leurs intercommunalités et
ce sont d'ailleurs souvent des communes
centre d'intercommunalité donc je suis
assez sensible à ce que disait Michel
gros tout à l'heure sur le rapport des
communes à leurs intercommunalités j'en
redirai un mot dans mon propos
une différence à mon avis la différence
principale entre les communes rurales et
les communes de notre strat c'est le
ratio entre les le nombre des deux et la
population d'un côté et le nombre de
d'agents municipaux et la population de
l'autre pour avoir fait des comparaisons
dans mon territoire je suis frappé d'une
chose c'est qu'en fait les communes
rurales sont plutôt très bien lotis en
termes de nombreux élus pour 1000
habitants il y a une forte présence
d'élus un ratio de nombreuses pour 1000
habitants élevés au dessus d'une aux
alentours d'une quinzaine ou dans ces
dans ces eaux là alors que dans les
communes de notre strat on est à un élu
pour 1000 habitants en général pas loin
alors inverse les communes rurales sont
plutôt très peu dotées en termes d'agent
pour 1000 habitants et finalement les
élus sont à la fois directeurs chefs de
service et parfois ouvriers alors que
dans nos communes nous avons la chance
d'avoir des administrations plus amples
je prends un exemple à Douai moi si je
veux un budget je sors pas mon tableau
Excel j'appelle la directrice du budget
si je veux un moment donné que un appel
à projet soit rédigé de l'ingénierie
derrière moi voilà donc c'est à mon avis
cette différence là principalement entre
les communes rurales et les communes de
notre strat
ce que les communes attendent à mon sens
peut se résumer en trois mots c'est
visibilité ou temps long les deux sont
synonymes autonomie et souplesse et je
me retrouve d'ailleurs à ce titre dans
beaucoup de choses qui a été dit par les
collègues juste avant alors sur le temps
long et la visibilité justement c'est de
ça que nous avons manqué dans les années
qui ont précédé et c'est vrai que la
crise les deux crises peut-être qui ont
été les plus dures pour nous ça a été la
crise sanitaire où il a fallu tout
inventer au quotidien et parfois
d'ailleurs on se retrouvant au début de
la crise un peu tout seul c'est-à-dire
que toutes les administrations d'État et
fermer le rideau en se disant comment on
fait pour arrêter de travailler d'abord
et nous on s'est dit comment on fait
pour continuer à travailler
ceux qui sont en première ligne et qui
doivent au contact du citoyen inventer
les solutions au moment ils ont plus
personne à côté d'eux
la crise que nous vivons actuellement
sur le l'inflation sur les
pénuries de matériaux etc est aussi très
compliqué à gérer parce que nous
travaillons sur des projets sur du temps
long parfois à l'échelle de deux ou
trois mandats les plans plus réels
d'investissement c'est des plans sur 5
ou 6 ans et qui en réalité parfois
encore une fois dépasse l'échelle d'un
mandat quand on met en place un service
même pas seulement en investissement
donc en fonctionnement aussi on
travaille sur plusieurs années donc on a
besoin de cette visibilité on a besoin
de cette stabilité on a besoin de
stabilité dans nos ressources de
visibilité dans nos ressources on a
besoin de stabilité du cadre juridique
deuxième terme que je voulais souligner
c'est l'autonomie alors autonomie à la
fois vis-à-vis de l'État et autonomie là
je reviens je reviendrai sur ce que
disait le collège juste avant autonomie
dans notre organisation nos choix
d'organisation localement à l'échelle du
bloc communal autonomie vis-à-vis de
l'État nous avons effectivement et ça a
été dit par un intervenant parfois le
sentiment que l'État a mesure qu'il se
déprend de ses propres moyens
d'ingénierie de sa capacité à faire peut
devenir de plus en plus tatillon ou ceux
recroqueviller sur une thématique ou son
incapacité à contrôler avec parfois
aussi y compris dans les villes de notre
strate peut-être un peu moins que dans
les villes les communes rurales mais
malgré tout une sorte de présomption
d'amateurs de certains
grands services de l'État notamment
centraux vis-à-vis des maires a priori
si un maire a un projet c'est sûrement
quelque chose d'électoraliste de trop
cher de mal adaptés et de mal monter
parce que le maire n'a pas la formation
nécessaire n'a pas les diplômes
nécessaires n'est pas sorti des bonnes
écoles et donc voilà il y a toujours un
petit soupçon sur ce que le maire a pu
monter il vaudrait mieux quand même
qu'une agence de l'État ou qu'un service
de ministère vient y mettre bonheur pour
que les choses soient faites comme il
faut
et ça c'est assez agaçant parce qu'en
réalité c'est souvent pas le cas je
prendrai quelques exemples en fin de
propos sur les types de relations
commune qui marche bien à mon sens et
celle qui sont assez frustrantes et
compliquées au quotidien autour de nous
donc autonomie vis-à-vis de l'État ne
pas se retrouver dans une position
d'exécutant de l'État je vais prendre un
exemple nous avons travaillé récemment
avec le sous préfet de mon
arrondissement sur un sujet qui le
nécessitait c'est les ERP des
établissements recevant du public
ok soit mais finalement je me suis
retrouvé un petit peu à devoir être
l'exécutant d'un pilotage par un État
qui est le sous-préfet n'y était pour
rien n'a plus les moyens de contrôler
lui-même les ERP n'a plus aucune
ingénierie pour le faire et donc de
temps en temps vient prendre le contrôle
de l'ingénierie des communes en disant
voilà vous allez me faire ça rendez-moi
des comptes
si l'État veut exercer une compétence ce
serait pas mal que de temps en temps il
garde la capacité à le faire lui-même et
à ne pas venir prendre
le municipal pour faire le travail à sa
place
sauf que la connaissance fine de du parc
des bailleurs en réalité c'est nous qui
l'avons c'est nous qui savons qui
habitent à quel endroit c'est nous qui
travaillons sur quelle famille on
installe dans quel logement etc et moi
je voudrais mettre en place dans ma
commune le permis de louer mon Dieu je
suis la seule commune de mon intercaut
36 communes à vouloir le faire mais on
m'a dit ah non non monsieur le maire
n'est pas le droit de mettre en place le
permis de Loïc Intercool de le voter oui
mais j'ai passé un accord avec interco
je vais prendre en charge toute
l'ingénierie de l'interco va pas me
verser un centime je vais tout faire je
vais recruter ça va d'ailleurs me coûter
cher parce qu'on n'a pas prévu que le le
propriétaire qui demande un permis de
louer paye ne serait-ce que le coût du
contrôle de son logement donc ça va me
coûter de l'argent mais je suis prêt à
le faire parce que c'est une compétence
importante ça fait trois ans que
j'attends l'intercommunalité n'a
toujours pas voté le permis de louer et
je n'ai pas le droit de le voter tout
seul voilà ces deux exemples parmi
d'autres pour vous montrer que on a
besoin de cette souplesse de cette
autonomie il y a des compétences où on
choisira toujours que ce soit la commune
qui fasse parce que que l'interco n'est
pas le bon niveau quand on est dans la
finesse de la relation avec l'habitant
quand on est sur la petite enfance quand
on est sur le scolaire quand on est sur
le social même parfois sur la politique
de la ville c'est pas forcément très
simple de le confier à l'interco
l'interco c'est une structure
d'ingénierie qui regarde les choses de
loin sur certains sujets comme le
développement économique c'est très bien
sur d'autres sujets quand on est dans
l'hyperproximité ça n'a pas de sens
une autre chose que je voudrais dire sur
l'interco et je rejoins ce que disait le
collègue l'État a toujours l'impression
que le bloc communal c'est un tout et
qu'il suffit de parler à l'interco et
tout le monde est au courant c'est pas
vrai c'est pas vrai l'interco c'est une
structure différente de la commune qui
gère ses propres compétences avec son
propre agenda et son propre projet
politique et elle ne les communes de
l'interco ne se réduisent pas l'une à
l'autre ce sont des projets politiques
différents et des strates différentes
avec des compétences différentes que
l'habitant
considère que c'est la même chose on
peut le comprendre c'est pas l'habitant
de gérer notre complexité donc
l'habitant et le collègue l'a dit
histoire vers le maire il lui dit ben
écoutez Monsieur le Maire madame le
Maire cette compétence c'est peut-être
l'interco mais moi vous êtes mon maire
je vous ai élu donc débrouillez vous
c'est à vous d'aller toquer à la porte
de l'interco c'est à vous d'aller gérer
le problème moi je passe le savoir la
poubelle déborde
et les habitants d'ailleurs n'ont pas de
relation avec l'interco enfin l'interco
a été construite d'une manière assez
on a fait Michel remichoux on n'est pas
allé comme en Belgique ou en Allemagne à
fusionné les communes mais on a créé une
strat supplémentaire sans en supprimer
une autre bon on n'est pas demandeur
qu'on supprime les communes donc très
bien on n'était pas forcément demandeur
que l'interco soit poussé à marche
forcée de cette manière par l'État il se
trouve qu'aujourd'hui les interco
existent gère des projets de nature
politique et non plus des projets
techniques comme c'était le cas des
syndicats avant or les intercos n'ont
aucun compte à rendre aux citoyens il
faut le souligner des interco leur corps
électorale ce sont les mers donc elle
parle Homer elle rendait compte Homère
et dans beaucoup de territoires
d'ailleurs le projet territorial de
l'interco s'il existe n'est pas présenté
pendant les élections municipales c'est
pas un sujet on parle chaque commune
parle du des sujets municipaux et le
projet de l'interco se gère entre mer
voilà
donc l'État serait avisé en revanche
parce que autant le citoyen n'a pas à
gérer notre complexité mais l'État lui
doit comprendre que les mers et
l'interco les communes à l'interco c'est
pas la même chose l'État doit parler aux
interco sur les compétences
intercommunales mais doit parler aux
maires sur les compétences communales
termine avec parce que j'ai été long le
la souplesse
on a besoin parce que justement nous
travaillons sur le temps long parce que
les sujets sont complexes parce que nous
sommes au croisement de plein de
problématiques parce que le maire est
fondamentalement un ensemble lié nous
avons besoin que l'État nous facilite la
vie et effectivement ça a été dit par un
interlocuteur les appels à projets par
exemple c'est quelque chose de très
compliqué
non seulement en termes de charge
d'ingénierie mais parce qu'en fait les
appels à projets viennent nous bousculer
quand nous sommes dans une logique de
mise en place sur le temps long dans une
vraie cohérence d'ensemble de toutes nos
politiques et sur un appel à projet il
faut faire semblant de sortir quelque
chose de tout neuf et de tout nouveau de
son chapeau juste pour avoir quelques
sous pour en réalité financer du temps
long
on a besoin de souplesse aussi et là
c'est je parlais du fait du maire
enseigné on a besoin d'avoir un état
ensemble lié et un état qui regarde les
choses de manière croisée en face de
nous qui comprennent à quel point ce que
nous touchons et systémique nous ne
touchons pas des sujets juxtaposés nous
tousons un écosystème nous gérons des
écosystèmes locaux et c'est pour ça que
souvent les mers apprécient la relation
avec le préfet vont encore le
sous-préfet surtout dans un département
qui a la population d'une région comme
le Nord parce que c'est enfin un état à
une seule tête et qui est un ensemble
billet et qui est capable de nous
répondre de manière croisée sur
plusieurs thématiques c'est compliqué
d'avoir à faire 15 agences de l'État ou
15 direction régionale de l'État qui
parfois ne se parlent pas à un ABS local
qui ne dit pas la même chose que la BF
qui est au dessus et qu'il dit encore
pas la même chose que les pompiers quand
on travaille sur un bâtiment à sécuriser
quand sur un PLU on a d'un côté le
sous-préfet qui nous dit il faut
construire de toute urgence parce qu'il
y a une usine de batterie qui vient dans
le Douaisis donc sortez-moi des projets
de construction et de rénovation de
logement et de l'autre côté la DDTM qui
dit avait quand même dans votre plu
alors même que vous êtes en zone vous
avez beaucoup de construction de
logements sur des friches donc
échelonner les parce qu'il faut pas tout
sortir tout de suite
ok bon voilà donc cette capacité à voir
en face de nous un état ensemble lié un
état qui parle d'une seule voix c'est
important et aussi si possible des sous
préfets et des préfets qui assument de
temps en temps d'arbitré il y a des cas
il y a des cas où la loi est pas
totalement claire et où on peut
l'interpréter dans un sens ou dans un
autre où il y a une marge de manœuvre
que l'État utilise cette marge de
manœuvre et il l'utilise dans un sens de
simplification à l'égard des mères en
disant écoutez là on assume il y a une
petite zone de flux de flou allez-y on
vous couvre
c'est pas souvent que ça arrive et c'est
quelque chose qui pourrait être très
utile je termine parce que j'ai été long
je vais laisser la parole à Eric mais
avec quelques exemples concrets de
choses qui marchent bien
et qui marche moins bien je vais
commencer par ce qui marche moins bien
allez tous les schémas qu'on nous
demande de faire à longueur de temps on
y passe des heures et ça finit dans un
tiroir chez nous on a fait
une convention de sécurité intégrée bon
ok on a mis par écrit tout ce qu'on
faisait au quotidien ça m'a pas rapporté
un policier national de plus et je vais
encore attendre six mois pour avoir une
réponse sur les caméras mobiles que je
vais installer à Douai donc cette CSI
elle a fini dans un tiroir
le CRPE qui est encore un machin on a
passé des heures à rédiger en général on
fait long pour faire sérieux et ça
n'avance pas plus que ça les projets
des sujets qui ne marchent pas très bien
le contrat de ville où on saupoudre il
n'y a pas de cohérence et chaque année
on passe des heures en mobilisant une
ingénierie énorme voilà pour financer
une vingtaine de projets leur rue
typiquement le cas de cette grande
agence de l'État qui vient nous dire
avec beaucoup de morts qu'il faut
multiplier les études pour à la fin
sortir ce que les mers savaient depuis
le début et enfin obtenir les
financements mais qu'on va nous mesurer
en vérifiant à chaque fois qu'on sait
les utiliser parce que il y a ce soupçon
permanent allez ce qui fonctionne bien
en revanche ce qui fonctionne pas mal
c'est quand on est sur un soutien souple
de l'État sur des projets de temps long
ou la stratégie vraiment définie par le
territoire le programme de récit
éducative ça ça marche bien ça c'est
chouette ce genre de projet et c'est ce
qui marche mieux chez moi dans le
contrat de ville la cité éducative
malheureusement ça ne durera que trois
ans mais là on est vraiment dans quelque
chose qui est construit par le
territoire les mers ont la main et on
nous laisse une vraie autonomie
d'initiative d'invention de ce que nous
voulons faire action cœur de ville
action cœur de ville ça marche pas mal
c'est quelque chose sur lequel ville de
France est un partenaire
évident de l'État mais c'est typiquement
le genre de dispositif portait justement
par un préfet qui connaît bien les mers
ou les mers ont été laissés à la
manoeuvre et chaque territoire a inventé
son action cœur de ville à sa manière
avec ses à partir de ses besoins ce qui
m'inquiète d'ailleurs c'est que j'ai
récemment compris que le président
interrogé beaucoup ce dispositif en
disant mais c'est quand même pas très
bien contrôlé par les tâches chacun fait
ce qu'il veut de son côté on comprend
pas très bien la cohérence d'ensemble
est-ce qu'action cœur de ville est un
bon dispositif bah vu des mères oui vu
de l'Élysée peut-être moins
je vais m'arrêter là parce que j'ai été
très long je veux laisser la parole à
Éric mais voilà dans un premier temps
quelques éléments que en tant que maire
d'une ville de 40000 habitants je
pouvais vous partager merci de votre
attention
si Monsieur le Maire et sachez que votre
présence sur la maturisme a fait
recettes chez nos collègues
merci j'ai passé la parole à Éric
strumman et puis après je laisserai la
parole au collègue afin qu'il puisse
eux-mêmes vous interroger les uns et les
autres merci
voilà bonjour Eric strummann je suis
maire de Colmar 70 000 habitants une
agglomération que je lui précise
également sans dix mille habitants
alors je réponds à l'avenir de la
communauté du maire l'avenir du maire je
crois que les Français sont très très
attachés à la figure du maire j'étais
président de département j'ai été
parlementaire
non concitoyens une relation très
particulière avec le maire c'est un
attachement historique et
je crois qu'il faut maintenir l'image du
maire comme ça au sein de la population
même s'il y avait que la montée des
réseaux sociaux
ça devient parfois plus difficile de
faire passer de des messages et on se
retrouve parfois avec des des
contradicteurs
qui ne participent pas de la même façon
que ça passait dans le temps au débat
public
mais je crois effectivement cette
fonction de maire doit être défendue
alors je vais répondre très concrètement
le maire pour la question qui a été
posée précédemment quelles sont les
compétences que la commune doit
conserver pour que le maire puisse
subsister dans ses fonctions il faut
quand même que la commune exerce un
certain nombre de compétences très
clairement la commune doit s'occuper des
écoles du périscolaire la commune doit
s'occuper de l'urbanisme à partir du
moment où le maire ne s'occupe plus
d'urbanisme je crois que le compte a le
compte à rebours de la fin de la commune
et de la fonction de maire va démarrer
il va s'occuper de culture de de sport
parce que là aussi je pense qu'on a
assez à faire au niveau des structures
intercommunales pour bien que ces
communes
occupent de ces fonctions
un autre pastèque qui n'a pas été abordé
c'est nos relations avec les
départements les régions moi je pense
très clairement qu'on a une strate en
trop
c'est la course lorsqu'on in derrière le
couplet de ruban des différents
financeurs nos concitoyens même
nous-mêmes on ne comprend plus
exactement qui fait quoi et je crois
qu'il y a un Big Bang institutionnel qui
se prépare et il faut il faut réduire
d'une strate
cette échelle pour le rendre plus
compréhensible par nos concitoyens et
par nos services une chose qui
fonctionne bien je dirais c'est des
espaces françaises qui ont été mises en
place après les gilets jaunes faut pas
parler plus de ce qui ne fonctionne pas
on l'a évoqué mais les espaces en
service qui d'ailleurs au départ était
plutôt réservés
aux communes rurales et bien je me rends
compte elle fonctionne très bien en zone
urbaine en particulier dans de nos
quartiers de reconquête républicaine ou
les gens ont plus de difficultés pour
des raisons intellectuelles financières
pratiques d'accéder à Internet voilà ce
que je souhaite vous dire
en complément et je retrouve évidemment
ce qui a été dit par mes collègues
précédemment
si beaucoup je vais maintenant peut-être
passer
la parole aux collègues qui souhaitent
vous interroger je ne sais pas qui
a marché oui mais merci beaucoup madame
la présidente monsieur le rapporteur
bonjour messieurs les mères il y a une
question qui peut-être n'a pas été
abordée c'est celle de l'assainissement
et de l'eau et le report éventuel de la
prise de compétence par les communautés
de communes de cette compétence qui
jusque là est facultatif qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire quel est votre
point de vue là-dessus
deux questions Jean-Michel Arnaud oui
merci monsieur le président madame la
Présidente il a été évoqué rapidement
tout à l'heure la question
l'attractivité
de la fonction publique territoriale et
des RH aurait une question
à vous poser sur l'articulation
haussièreh entre le niveau communal et
intercommunal je constate qu'un certain
interne
a fait le choix d'une mutualisation
intégrée qui se traduit bien souvent
par une absorption et une mutualisation
des services de la ville centre avec
l'intercommunalité ce qui crée me
semble-t-il des difficultés
d'appropriation des agents
intercommunaux et aussi de la liaison
entre les personnels communaux des
communes membres de l'interconnalité
avec leurs collègues de la ville centres
est-ce que vous avez sur ce sujet un
éclairage une observation particulière
ou des suggestions à nous faire merci
merci Cécile ku Karman
merci pour les différentes interventions
qui effectivement je crois sont en plis
de de réalité et j'oser de vrai vie en
tout cas auquel toutes et tous peuvent
être confrontés
une remarque et une question sur sur ce
qui a été dit effectivement vous avez
évoqué
l'enjeu finalement pour que le l'échelon
communal et donc le pouvoir du maire
mais plus largement du conseil municipal
soit aussi respecté reconnu la question
du nombre de compétences et finalement
de ce qui reste
à pouvoir faire si ce n'est simplement
recevoir les gens quand ils viennent
toquer à la porte de la mairie l'un
d'entre vous je crois le dernier
intervenant à évoqué tous les enjeux
d'urbanisme dont on voit effectivement
que il tendent à se réduire dans la
capacité du pouvoir du maire dans ce
domaine là y compris avec la
multiplication de pluie et de tout ce
qui va autour je ne développe pas notre
collègue Anne Charles vient d'évoquer la
question de l'eau et de l'assainissement
est-ce que à vos yeux il y a d'autres
compétences qui auraient peut-être été
remontée de façon parfois un peu brutale
ou en tout cas à caractère obligatoire
qui aujourd'hui viennent à manquer parce
que la question maintenant n'est pas
d'avoir une collection comme dans un
album Panini du nombre de compétences
communales mais en revanche
effectivement de pouvoir exercer des
missions pour redonner aussi de la
légitimité face à nos concitoyens du
pouvoir du pouvoir du maire merci merci
Christian rebond sarrazzi oui merci
monsieur madame la Présidente je le
rapporteur et Messieurs les maires de de
vos précisions
je complèterai le propos de mon collègue
Arnaud concernant donc les difficultés
des équipes administratives dans les
communes et peut-être interrogé par
rapport notamment à
l'absence maintenant de d'interlocuteur
au niveau des finances publiques qui
dans bien des cas posent un vrai
problème
c'est les maisons France service ne sont
pas du tout de réponse une réponse à ce
problème et le conseiller fiscal qui a
été mis en place et qui aujourd'hui dans
certains cas peut avoir plus d'une
centaine de d'interlocuteurs pour les
budgets notamment et est un vrai
problème mais est-ce que ça ne contribue
pas à rendre gérer le le l'exercice du
métier de secrétaire de mairie encore
plus complexe et peut-être moins
attractif fut hier aux difficultés
rencontrées
merci je vais vous redonner la parole
messieurs les maires je ne sais pas qui
souhaitent commencer à répondre aux
quatre questions qui qui sont posées
monsieur strowman voilà comme j'étais le
moins bavard tout à l'heure ou à
assainissement en Alsace il y a aucun
problème parce qu'on puisse dans la
nappe phréatique d'Alsace et je crois
que dans le Bas-Rhin il y a sadicat
unique pour l'ensemble des communes du
bas quasiment toutes les communaux
adhérer donc il y a pas de difficultés
particulières en matière de
l'assainissement ça peut être différent
ailleurs en France ou on cherche l'eau
sur différents bassins de collecte pour
les arbres l'urbanisme moi je reste
convaincu à partir du moment où vous
mettez en place un plu et que
l'urbanisme géré par l'intercommunalité
et bien ça réduit considérablement les
pouvoirs du maire et c'est le compte à
rebours pour la disparition de la
commune j'en suis voilà c'est mon avis
personnel je suis passé c'est la vie de
l'association mais je le vis comme ça
sur mon territoire et donc pour tous les
maires on est toujours favorable au
maintien de la compétence urbanisme dans
les communes ensuite nous on a une
difficulté mais je crois que ça français
général que ce soit les grandes communes
ou c'est peut-être plus facile de
recruter mais dans les petites communes
de trouver des secrétaires généraux de
mairie c'était devenu d'Henri
extrêmement rare
ou d'ailleurs les différents collègues
évidemment font monter les prix et ce
pique les secrétaires généraux d'une
commune à l'autre je me demande s'il
faudrait pas réfléchir vraiment créer un
diplôme de secrétaire de mairie
une formation structurée
à travers l'université ou des écoles ça
existait dans le temps il y avait des
écoles pratiques d'administration qui
ont disparu et pour trouver un vivier de
recrutement de secrétaire de mairie qui
chez nous sont devenus une denrée rare
merci Monsieur gros
oui merci pour le nouveau donc sur la
quelques réponses sur les questions
concernant la compétence eau et
assainissement j'ai eu l'occasion de
l'évoquer tout à l'heure mais j'ai bien
développé
depuis que nous on est à communauté
d'agglo depuis que la compétence a été
transférée de manière obligatoire à la
communauté d'agglo en gros on fait
double travail c'est à dire que les
besoins émanent bien entendu de la
commune c'est nous qui devons faire le
travail de recherche de
pour faire les travaux c'est à dire
rechercher l'entreprise qui va nous
accompagner etc préparer tout toute la
paperasse administrative ensuite ça part
à l'intercommunalité l'intercommunalité
valide le ou pas le dossier ensuite il
faut que le commissaire communautaire
vote tout ça et puis après on peut faire
les travaux donc on voit bien que en
termes de réactivité en termes de lourde
administrative le fait d'avoir transféré
la compétence eau et assainissement à
l'intercommunalité n'a pas vraiment de
n'est pas vraiment exemplaire d'autant
que et moi je ne peux parler que pour
les communes rurales en tout cas
évidemment dedans que c'est un sujet
très sensible nous sommes sensibles à
l'eau puis comme je le disais tout à
l'heure dans mon premier propos l'eau
pour la plupart du temps elle est allé
territoires ruraux donc on y fait très
attention et au niveau de
l'assainissement c'est pareil donc
l'État a suffisamment de contrôle sont
sur les stations d'épuration et les
rendements de réseau d'eau sans pour
autant contraindre la
mutualisation est passée à
l'intercommunalité le
constate ça a été une question qui a été
posée sur les RH parce qu'on constate en
tout cas c'est que le moi je le vois
depuis la fusion en 2017 et bien le coût
des RH au niveau de l'intercommunalité
que ne fait que croître et alors que
nous bien entendu il n'y a pas eu
forcément de transfert de personnel au
niveau de l'agglo si ce n'est des
crèches
et toute la partie plu toute la partie
gestion de l'eau enfin les élus et où la
DGS qui s'occupe du de tout ça les
marchés publics et bien c'est toujours
rester en la commune et c'est nous qui
le faisons donc le fait d'avoir
transféré à l'intercommunalité n'a pas
fait d'économie d'échelle et comme elle
le dit en entreprise nationale
depuis des années qu'il connaît les
échelles ils jamais dû faire des
économies donc ça mais c'est dit on est
également opposé au plui le plui ça a
été dit par un collègue est une de la
commune de Colmar donc on voit bien
qu'entre 70 000 habitants et une commune
de 2500 habitants comme la mienne il y a
un grand écart mais pour autant on se
rejoint là dessus c'est à dire que le
PLU doit être doit rester à la main du
maire et du conseil municipal pour être
vraiment en phase avec le besoin et les
attentes de la population
il y a des communes qui veulent se
développer pour y aller raison et c'est
respectable j'ai pas à juger mais une
demeure pas moins qu'on doit nous
laisser la liberté de le faire et puis
encore une fois l'état est là pour
encadrer si d'aventure il y a des des
dérives
et enfin ça a été évoqué les aides de
l'État qui disparaissent les aides
techniques notamment le conseiller
fiscal alors le quantité fiscal
en nous a vendu ça comme étant la
panacée puisque bien entendu comme on a
rationalisé on n'a pas dit fermé on a
dit rationaliser les
[Musique]
trésorerie donc ça veut dire fermer en
fait et on nous a mis un conseiller
fiscal puisque bien entendu en parallèle
de ça on nous a contraint de passer à la
M57 puis on a contraint à tout un tas de
choses qui font que l'État si ça ne suis
probablement un peu coupable et nous
aide avec un conseiller fiscal alors je
peux pas parler pour les collègues et je
sais pas ce qu'ils le feront eux-mêmes
mieux que moi à ce qu'il est concerne
mais je dois dire que dans mon dans le
bassin dans lequel je suis bassin de vie
à laquelle je suis le conseiller fiscal
est très efficace et j'avoue que il nous
il apporte de précieux conseils
notamment auprès de ma DGS voilà
merci Monsieur Chereau si vous voulez
rajouter un
quelques mots pour compléter ce qu'on
peut dire très bien mes collègues sur
l'eau et l'assainissement chez moi c'est
géré par l'intercommunalité c'est plutôt
satisfaisant alors sachant qu'on est
quand même dans une situation complexe
ou une grande partie de
l'intercommunalité est couverte par un
syndicat d'échelle départementale et
l'omération de gérer l'assainissement
finalement pour la moitié des communes
environ le principal les deux écueils
que j'y vois c'est d'un côté la gestion
du calendrier des interventions sur un
chantier de voirie l'agglomération fait
donc partie des concessionnaires et on
sait que pour l'acceptabilité par la
population des chantiers de voirie il
faut être vraiment capable de gérer le
phasage de ces différentes interventions
faire en sorte que les interventions
autant que possible ce chevauchent ou
s'enchaîne le plus efficacement possible
et forcément plus il y a d'intervenant
plus ce calendrier des interventions sur
la voirie peut être perturbé moi ça
m'arrive quelquefois d'avoir mis à mon
plan d'investissement une voirie l'agglo
me dit oui bah nous on va faire notre
intervention assainissement c'est prévu
d'accord et finalement quand moi je suis
prêt dans ces mes appels d'offres
l'agglo me dit en fait non on est un peu
en retard on a d'autres chantiers on va
pas pouvoir ce sera pas cette année ou
alors on le fera en fin d'année
voilà ça c'est parfois un petit peu
perturbant l'autre aspect on n'est pas
exactement dans l'eau et
l'assainissement on est plutôt dans la
gestion des inondations le I de gemapi
et la gestion des risques et là parfois
en fait le périmètre pertinent les mêmes
pas l'agglomération il est au-delà nous
dans le Nord on est un territoire plutôt
plat ou tous les cours d'eau sont plus
ou moins reliés entre eux ont été très
entrepisés depuis des siècles parfois
depuis le haut moyen-âge et donc le
réseau est très complexe et il faudrait
pratiquement qu'on crée nous un
établissement public territorial de
bassin qui aille du bassin minier
jusqu'à la métropole de Lille sur 4 ou 5
agglomérations et deux départements il y
a cet échelle là ça pourrait être
intéressant pour le coup que l'État
prenne un peu la main parce que ça
commence à devenir très compliqué de
gérer ses échelles en partant simplement
du niveau des communes ou des
intercommunalités sur ce qu'on dit mes
collègues sur le fait de garder un
pouvoir d'ingénierie aux communes oui
100 fois oui je vais aller un peu à
l'encontre de la doxa qui je pense
circule dans les
ministères mais j'aurais tendance à
penser que
l'ingénierie et le comment dire le
projet stratégique de territoire doit
d'abord être quelque chose qui
appartient aux communes parce que les
communes sont élues sur un projet
politique en direct face à la population
et qu'en revanche les agglomérations
doivent davantage être sur des
compétences
et moins politique au choix des mers et
des communes qui composent ces affaires
communalité
nous avons besoin de garder la main sur
l'urbanisme ça c'est absolument
fondamental c'est vrai le passage au
pluvi a été souvent vécu comme très
difficile une perte de substances par
beaucoup de communes et quand on est
dans des agglomérations comme la
métropole européenne de l'île de Lille
sur 100 commune ou un collègue le disait
tout à l'heure on est même plus capable
de connaître les autres mères et ça
c'est important appelé chacun par son
prénom savoir qui est qui quand on est
sans commune on peut pas moi chez moi
c'est 36 ça va encore mais des pluies à
cette échelle ça devient la chose des
services et les services de
l'intercommunalité parlent à l'État et
les mers sont dépossédés de ce qui est
fondamentalement leur métier leur outil
stratégique numéro un le PLU sur leur
commune et en plus quand on doit faire
une modification sur un pluie ça c'est
quelque chose que ville de France dépend
au moins quand il y a des pays lui qu'on
soit capable de faire des modifications
à petit échelle qui concerne une ou deux
communes sans lancer tout un barnum de
consultation où tout le monde doit
donner son avis
les maires ne doivent pas demain ce
serait mortifère pour les communes ne
doivent pas être ceux qui simplement
gèrent le quotidien gèrent
voilà les gens qui viennent toquer à la
porte parce qu'ils ont un trou dans le
trottoir parce qu'ils ont besoin d'un
logement parce que ils veulent une
dérogation dans telle ou telle école si
on se retrouve à simplement gérer ces
petits sujets sans être capable de
piloter d'une stratégique alors oui
effectivement c'est la mort de la
commune
en parlant d'ingénierie je terminerai
là-dessus c'est peut-être une attente
forte que nous avons pour être en
capacité de gérer nos projets nous
aurions besoin parfois de soutien de
l'État en termes d'ingénierie nous avons
du soutien de l'État en termes de
finances c'est bien mais parfois sur
certains projets on a l'impression que
vu de l'état tout ce qui est du
fonctionnement c'est c'est dangereux
c'est de la c'est du gaspillage c'est il
y a toujours un risque de gabgie il faut
jamais mettre d'argent sur le
fonctionnement voilà moyenne en quoi par
exemple la dotation politique de la
ville chez moi aujourd'hui le préfet a
décidé c'est plus qu'en investissement
c'est pas en fonctionnement or pour
porter des projets pour préparer
l'avenir par exemple elle est inventée
de nouvelles sources de production
d'énergie locale
transformer nos centres-villes par
exemple sur des sujets comme cela ou
porter simplement moi je dois demain
créer une nouvelle cuisine centrale avec
une approche de projet assez intégré
dans le projet éducatif de territoire
c'est intégré c'est en lien avec le
projet alimentaire de territoire je dois
dans quelques années j'ai le projet de
créer un
grand pôle petit enfance intégrant une
maternelle une école élémentaire et une
crèche pour porter ce genre de projet il
nous faut de l'ingénierie et si l'État
était capable de nous apporter des
soutiens financiers pour financer
pendant deux ans trois ans des contrats
de projet ce serait extrêmement précieux
parce que ces projets ne sortent au bout
d'un moment que quand on a quelqu'un de
bien cortiqué à mettre sur le dossier et
qui s'y consacre à 100%
merci beaucoup je me tourne vers les
collègues y a-t-il d'autres questions
s'il n'y en a pas oui j'en sol oui
monsieur le rapporteur messieurs merci
pour pour vos éclairages en tout cas sur
ce que vous viviez au quotidien moi je
voudrais revenir sur ce qu'a exprimé
notre rapporteur tout à l'heure
notamment sur le statut de l'élu d'une
part et puis sur les difficultés enfin
que vous constatez pluri quotidiennement
mais qui sont aussi exprimés par les
secrétaires notamment nos secrétaires de
mairie je ne parle pas des directrices
de de service diplômés compétentes mais
des secrétariats de de mairie dont il
faut parfois s'accommoder
merci gens qui souhaitent répondre
ce gros
oui je veux bien oui
[Musique]
la question renvoie au statut au statut
de Lenny les deux l'élu si vous voulez
aujourd'hui
alors ce que je dis est vrai aujourd'hui
puis après quand on va arriver plus près
de 2026 les il va y avoir des des
poussées de gens qui veulent s'occuper
de la mairie mais en fait quand on
regarde la
le maire on est responsable de tout et
on ne réalise pas tant qu'on n'est pas
élu combien on est sur le fil en
permanence en fait le moindre pépin
c'est sur le maire que ça retombe de
manière juridique de manière un problème
financier également on a des budgets à
gérer alors si on est si on est expert
ou si on peut s'entourer de personnes
qui peuvent nous aider tout va bien mais
si on n'est pas entouré ou si on n'est
pas aidé c'est compliqué donc les
formations des élus le soutien de l'État
à travers le à travers une aide comme ça
a été dit tout à l'heure un ingénierie
mais également un soutien on l'a évoqué
tout à l'heure avec le
conseiller fiscal
serait de nature à permettre aux maires
de générer une certaine appétence pour
la
fonction numérique qui est vraiment très
très difficile et j'avoue que très
souvent
ça pas encore été évoqué mais quand on
se pose la question de savoir la
vocation des maires il y a une perte de
sens également qui se qui se fait jour
parce que des fois on dit mais pourquoi
on s'inflige ça pourquoi on fait on fait
tout ça sachant qu'encore une fois on
compte pas nos heures on compte pas nos
responsabilités et là
et puis à côté de ça on a face à nous
des citoyens qui deviennent des
administrés qui soient des consommateurs
et qui donc
ne prennent pas en compte une mesure pas
le travail qui doit être accompli pour
faire avancer ne serait-ce que d'un peu
la la chose publique et là l'état mon
avis en tout cas à un rôle il faut
afficher il faut que l'État affiche haut
et fort la volonté de soutenir les
communes les communes rurales en
particulier parce que moi je suis vice
président des meilleurs bureaux mais
toutes les communes en général
et que cette spécificité qui fait la
France qui fait ce maillage très fort au
cœur de tous les territoires c'est les
communes qui le font on est un tout ce
qui est à réussir quand on a eu les
gilets jaunes dont on recommence à
parler aujourd'hui qui a fait les
cahiers de doléances qui a fait remonter
à l'état c'est les communes et c'est les
communes rurales principalement étaient
à l'origine bon tout ça ça a été scanné
ni bien au chaud dans un placard et ça
n'a pas été traité pourtant on est en
phase à une auto population on le voit
on le voit on sait ce qu'ils attendent
en tout cas quand on est on essaie de
s'occuper correctement notre commune
donc
pour conclure si vous voulez moi ce que
je voudrais dire c'est c'est pour faire
simple
[Musique]
si j'avais dit quelque chose à dire à
l'état d'ailleurs je l'ai déjà fait mais
il semblerait qu'il soit pas le cas
trois choses la première des choses
c'est de dire écoutez nous quand on dit
les choses écouter nous vous n'avez
l'État n'a pas à la science infuse nous
non plus mais en tout cas nous ce qu'on
peut dire c'est que on n'a pas la
prétention de vouloir gérer la France
mais on a peut-être la prétention de
gérer nos communes donc écouter nous nos
besoins quand on les exprime ils sont
réels aidez-nous quand vous avez entendu
ce qu'on vous a demandé aidez-nous ne
nous mettez pas ne nous mettez pas
systématiquement des barrières c'est
toujours du oui mais non oui on va vous
aider mais on peut pas le faire donc
c'est toujours compliqué et 3
faites-nous confiance c'est à dire que à
partir du moment
où on a vous nous aidez faites-nous
confiance là on est soumis à des règles
de contrôle qui sont draconiennes et qui
sont ah oui mais là vous comprenez la
ligne à caisse de l'aligné 22 n'a pas
été remplie on vous enlève de la 2 tiers
où vous n'avez pas droit à ça c'est
inacceptable c'est inacceptable voilà
merci merci beaucoup messieurs en tout
cas pour pour vos témoignages on va
conclure et je vais remercier aussi nos
collègues nos collègues qui étaient
nombreux ce matin autour de la table
vos éclairages ont été pour nous très
très instructifs même si on partage
beaucoup de ce que vous avez dit en
ayant été maire nous aussi dans une
autre vie mais quelques années d'un des
territoires très ruraux et je on s'est
beaucoup retrouvé dans vos dans vos
constats et dans vos préoccupations
vous dire aussi que le Sénat se
préoccupe au quotidien de la vie des
communes non pas cap travers cette cette
mission puisque cette semaine il y a pas
moins de cinq propositions de loi qui
seront étudiées en séance qui concerne
les collectivités notamment le zan
notamment la compétence soit
assainissement donc pour vous dire que
on est à vos côtés et notre notre
conviction profonde et que la commune
reste une strate et d'une importance
majeure pour pour l'avenir de notre pays
et pour le lien social de nos
territoires merci en tout cas à vous
tous et puis au plaisir de vous
retrouver au gré de d'autres réunions
merci merci en tout cas au revoir merci